it is chris flexon a 3-8-0 earned run
average making his 16th start and he has
just been fantastic for the mariners
here comes the best player in baseball
at the moment absolutely he has had an
amazing season really an all-time half a
season
payoff pitch to ohtani
and he loses him on ball four
there he goes
pitches strike throw to second and time
and they got him
for flexing throwing over a couple of
times a late jump
tom murphy gets rid of it quickly
[Applause]
and there's the tag clearly out
so ohtani that one out walk is cut down
flexing behind two and one now on walsh
a soft pop-up bowers in left field
tonight
puts it away flex and despite the walk
faces the minimum we go to the bottom of
the first mariners coming up
patrick sandoval as a starter great
returns in his eight assignments a two
and two record 3.46 era france was the
guy who was not in the original starting
lineup
and when kyle seeger was scratched
twitter in the pacific northwest went
nuts
france pops it up fletcher calling off
lagaras to retire the side in order on
behalf of patrick sandoval
to the second no score in seattle luis
torrance d.h tonight he caught last
night in the opener
got him swinging on the change-up
that's a good conversation here going
man that's a perfect change-up
so it's one and two to freely and he
gets him swinging at a change-up why not
it's that fate he'll throw that change
up down and into a lefty down and away
though righty
i don't want any drama tonight with this
scooby i don't want it coming down to
the ninth inning you know with
two out trying to extend the street the
statcast numbers aren't very sexy for
david fletcher get down drop that is 23
in a row got it
way to go matt good job
again that's not gonna be a hundred and
some mile an hour exit velocity but it
looks like a line drive for fletch 23
games he breakable not even a full
follow through on the contact it's all
about that contact percentage that's why
he always has a chance to pick up a hit
man aboard for ohtani
this works also
bauer's easy play for the left fielder
[Applause]
one out one on haniger at lead off walk
fair ball maybe just right on top of the
chuck
hanniger making his way into third base
terrence
ropes that single over first base so the
mariners now with runners down the
corners
oh here you go right on the outside
corner a little bit of a late swing but
it's going to work out for him right
down the line that is a fair ball 105 on
the exit velocity then it's right on the
chalk
[Applause]
ground ball fletcher down to second on
the first not in time and the mariners
get the first run of the night
here's the 2-2 pitch
to stassi flexing to the plate swaying
in a mess struck him out with a changeup
one out
and goes off speed here you go that's
the change up again gained a lot of
confidence in that pitch
that's been over the course of this
summer really taylor ward took a call
third strike
he froze him on the hook
12-6 curveball right towards the top of
the zone 75 miles an hour
outfield not real deep
for mayfield who's with the mariners
first spell this year as a pitch swung
on bounce down the third dylan moore
take it to the third base back for the
force app and that'll do it no runs two
hits no errors
and sandoval hoping to deliver them
there down just a run here's the 2-2
home got him swinging
six strikeouts for patrick sandoval
tonight after a one two three bottom of
the fifth
flexon facing the top of the order
dylan charging quick release on to first
in time
well aaron you were right they are
testing him a swinging bunt from
fletcher he was playing in
the charging get rid of it quickly so we
think fletcher likes swinging at the
first pitch i think he likes to be
aggressive
chris likes it
lead-off man retired in front of ohtani
[Applause]
oh
all right
ohtani
not agreed you can see why flexon will
gladly accept
well it's going back to the changeup
again mcdelivery super moment here's a
look at the change up
wow that's not even close that's one of
those ones it's tough to stay in the
game if you're joe joe madden i love
that at least
so a runner on first base there's two
outs mariners leading one nothing here
comes terence
terence laces this into right field
france making the turn this is hanging
up into the corner france is getting
waved in
here comes ty france coming home
he slides across without a throw to
nothing mariners at the bottom of the
sixth
he fires
he got him swinging how about the hook
to finish the night
seven masterful scoreless frames against
the angels tonight for chris flexon
another one too
there you go and his center field
bowers at two out now
and just hanging in there fouled off a
number of pitches
that's right on the corner probably at
the knees towards the end of the bat
soft line drive but he'll take it
into center but hang it up
lagaris
puts the squeeze on and for out number
three bowers stranded seven in the books
mariners have both runs
strikeout number one for second rider
he goes
back-to-back strikeouts for second rider
a wave and a miss
strikes out the side
[Applause]
the next full count pitch on its way to
long
a bouncing ball to third rojas
to walsh to retire the side without
incident bases left loaded
still a manageable deficit
to the ninth two-nothing seattle
another 2-2
how about another strikeout for seawall
the home run king headed back
last hope for the angels shortstop jose
iglesias
broken back dylan moore backhand by
third on to first it's a series win two
nothing mariners win